ils sont venus nombreux à Versailles
pour dire non à la réforme des retraites
selon la CGT des Yvelines 350
manifestants ont défilé dans les rues
pour le 5e jour de grève et de
mobilisation on sera à la manifestation
à Paris aussi mais c'était de démontrer
ici dans cette ville de Versailles entre
la préfecture le château le Medef et
tous les lieux de pouvoir ici en
Yvelines que le monde du travail en
Yvelines est mobilisé professeur
personnel hospitalier retraitée ou
encore employé territoriaux faisaient
partie du cortège objectif maintenir un
fil revendicatif et s'inscrire dans la
durée elle va pousser nous les petites
gens les gens qui sont cassés au boulot
qui ont une espérance de vie bien moins
grande que
des gens qui ne travaillent pas en
horaires décalé etc qui va nous pousser
à travailler plus longtemps sans doute
parfois mourir au travail ou à avoir des
pensions à moins de riz à cause de
réforme Touraine et de son accélération
le fait de pouvoir partir plus tôt c'est
une reconnaissance justement de la
pénibilité du travail c'est des acquis
sociaux c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
donne gratuitement aux gens il y a une
cotisation à toute cotisation qui
souvent est plus élevée il faut que les
gens prennent conscience que si on
bloque pas le pays de façon pourra
défiler pendant 10 ans on aura rien plus
d'une centaine de pompiers de plusieurs
syndicats ont également fait le
déplacement le gouvernement ils sont
contents de nous appeler sur tous les
théâtres d'opération et à côté de ça
derrière qu'est-ce qu'ils font bah ils
veulent qu'on travaille plus longtemps
et sachant que nous c'est impossible
pour nous à 60 ans vous imaginez bien
que par rapport à toutes les missions
qu'on a bah c'est ultra compliqué d'être
en forme et en bonne santé je vous cache
pas aussi que on fait pas 35 heures à
côté de ça on cumule tous les risques
professionnels qu'il existe quasiment le
texte de loi est examiné jusqu'au
vendredi 17 février à l'Assemblée
nationale mais les syndicats ne comptent
pas s'arrêter là si la prochaine date de
mobilisation et de grève est fixée aux 7
mars prochain à l'échelle nationale une
manifestation aux flambeau est prévue le
vendredi 17 février à Rambouillet